listen to me from Moscow to Samoa that  is not the easiest charter to get but I  got it that's why we're calling it  Dinkley we just want to say thank you  for getting us that bird to some on boys  how about warriors just know that  whatever you need you got yourself a  third squad he over here that can  deliver boys yeah listen [ __ ] you  don't have to do that voice with us all  right just talk normally you probably  had a little bit of frog in my throat I  got up early this morning got some  clanging and banging in 3:45 a.m. leg  day  you're not both no you don't take leg  days off shark machine to Dibble your  butt don't hit that bench it don't count  yeah  hey you know we got to get some banging  in man got to you get back I'm picking  you up we going straight to Gold's yeah  I got the membership of a pretty bad  that was my phone Carol remember that  big thing I told you I was working on  well it just happened I quit  you